okay our next speaker is max freezin max
is a professor of archaeology at the
University of Toronto and he does field
work all across the Arctic with a focus
on examining drivers of Arctic cultural
shifts over the past 5,000 years and Max
has published extensively on these
subjects notably who is currently
co-editing the Oxford Handbook of Arctic
archaeology and he's doing some very
interesting work now to investigate the
degradation of Arctic coastal
archaeological sites caused by
contemporary climate change Max's talk
today will be on two phases of Arctic
climate change past impacts on human
settlement future risks for
archaeological sites okay well thanks
very much for the invitation to this
wonderful workshop and I should start
out by saying that this might be false
advertising because I may only get to
the first of the two phases if I tend to
go long I'll just forget about the
second one but the the reference is to
two very different aspects of climate
change that are of concern to
archaeologists over the last many
decades Arctic archaeologists have of
course been aware of the fact that there
are there's climate change going on and
that it must have had impacts on past
human settlement the other one is a
concern that's come up mainly over the
last decade or so which is the
destruction of archaeological sites due
to modern and future climate change and
and there's just radical destructive
events going on all the time I have a
project myself that's trying to address
this that i'll get to in the second half
if i have time but for this first half I
thought for because of the purpose of
this conference I'm hoping it'll be
useful to basically just go through an
overview of Eastern Arctic prehistory
and the ways in which archaeologists
tend to interpret the linkages between
the the big processes the big events in
that prehistory on the one hand and
climate change on the other so don't
worry about this thing on the right it's
just intended to show you a sort of
historical approach a very important
paper berry at all 1977 one of the first
that tried to systematically put
together evidence for climate change
and evidence for some of the big events
in Arctic prehistory so just before
going into the actual prehistory I
wanted to go through just some of the
background and again I'm trying to
reflect kind of the zeitgeist in terms
of Eastern Arctic archaeologists and how
they perceive climate change archaeology
so archaeology in all regions but
certainly in the Eastern Arctic is often
seen in terms of a series of different
cultural groups different cultures or
traditions if you will interspersed with
big events like extinctions migrations
that kind of thing and or radical
adaptations major changes in the way
people make a living and in this case
I'm going to be trying to look at some
of those big events and see whether they
do more or less sync up with with
climate change most of the discussion in
literature is about long term century or
greater trends in climate change rather
than interannual or decayed all very
ability archeologists are aware of the
fact you know in fact sometimes it's
amazing how much variability there is
from year to year and there is an
assumption that periods with radical
interannual for example variability
would be very hard in some cases for
people to to live with but it's it's
hard to sync up the archaeological
records and the paleo environmental
records precisely enough often to put
those two together so usually
archaeologists rely more on broad trends
of warming and cooling that kind of
thing and also there is a lot of
regional variability in the Arctic as
you can as you can imagine but in this
case I'm going to just ignore that and
talk about the really big events the
really big processes so when Eastern
Arctic archaeologists and by Eastern
Arctic i'm referring really to the
entire Canadian Arctic Archipelago the
adjacent mainland and Greenland so it's
you know most of the North American
Arctic sort of Central and Eastern when
archaeologists think about climate
change and the potential impacts of
climate change they have a few specific
things in mind and much of this has to
do with reading the ethnographic record
of Inuit
opiate and related people's so I've
divided this in a very simplistic manner
into increasing warmth and increase in
cold and in cases where we see
increasing warmth in the record there is
an assumption first of all that there's
going to be more open water more open
water has direct consequences as we know
for the size and extent of populations
of many not all but many marine mammals
with whale species being particularly
important whether it's bowheads belugas
Narwhal or what have you walrus are
certainly impacted by the amount of open
water but open water is also conducive
to certain types of boat travel
especially travel by Umi ACK the big
open skin boats and so this nice
engraving shows you both a way elbow at
whale hunt and one of these big Umi acts
which of course with longer open water
periods would allow people to move much
greater distances but there's also
usually an assumption that there's going
to be greater terrestrial productivity
and because there are very few edible
plants the relevance to human settlement
is in greater numbers greater population
sizes for terrestrial mammals and
especially caribou muskox can be
important but caribou is almost always
important this ethnographic photo show I
chose it because it shows this fellow
drawing caribou meat and this is yet
another aspect of the Arctic of all
Arctic adaptations if you will is that
there's this brief highly productive
warm season when you have to put up lots
of stores in order to basically survive
through the winter with just a few
exceptions so therefore overall warm
periods are generally seen to be easier
to make a living their periods when
there's often it's often considered be
cultural stability not as much change
going on and also times when human
populations expand to take advantage of
new opportunities and again this is a
simplified version just to give you the
kind of the overview now contrast the
increasing warmth of increasing cold
well with increasing cold you get more
fastest and especially more of that one
year ice first year ice that was
one of the talks this morning now that's
bad for a lot of marine mammal species
but it's extremely good for ringed seals
which maintain breathing holes and which
actually can expand their numbers under
optimal sea ice conditions so there's a
lot more often ringed seals and
sometimes bearded seals which can also
maintain breathing holes sometimes it's
better for sled transport flat sea ice
travel in spring is too many Inuit the
best time to travel and but overall cold
or periods with increasing cold are
considered to to lead to issues to
problems these are periods when
presumably human populations contract
when it becomes more difficult to make a
living and possibly periods when human
societies get more creative and develop
new ways of making a living a living
from a particular area of land okay so
now on to the general Arctic prehistory
now I'm just going to try to give a
really basic overview and then tell you
just some of the big events that are
thought to have happened so overall the
prehistory of the eastern Turkey is
divided into just two main traditions
paleo Inuit or it's often called paleo
Eskimo the early one and Inuit the
second one now these are very distantly
related to each other there's an almost
complete cultural break between them
into it represents a new migration and
from Alaska about 800 years ago that
fully replaces the paleo Inuit who came
before them within each of these
traditions there are several sub
traditions or smaller groups and our
main are basic information about these
is pretty constant but some things are
changing and one of the things that the
aspects that have been changing recently
significantly as dating we're our start
and end dates for a lot of these things
are changing sometimes by up to five
hundred or a thousand years and of
course if you want to try to sync up the
archeology with climate if you start
changing the dates of for example the
first people of the Arctic by
pre dorset people that can have
implications for how it is going to work
out in terms of what what are the local
climates what are the the the poles to
draw to draw people into an area or the
pushes to drive them out of other areas
so I'm going to go through each of these
five sort of sub traditions if you will
just to give you a couple of the sort of
a thumbnail version of what's going on
and then turn to the potential for
climate to have having some impact pre
Dorset which it's much more complicated
there's multiple names for this but I'm
going with pre Dorset which is used in
much of the area pre Dorset originally
arose as part of the bell catch culture
in Siberia migrated into and through
Alaska well before five thousand BP
before 3000 BC and made it into the
Canadian Arctic we now are pretty sure
by about 3,200 Cal bc fifty two hundred
give or take a cal BP that's really
interesting because until just a few
years ago we thought it was about 4500
and in fact we don't have consistent
dates in Alaska that early there's a
couple of dates but none that early
which mainly has to do with the fact
that the sites are just so visible in
the Canadian Arctic if you remember the
the images of those series of beach
ridges I mean as an archaeologist you
can just basically fly up the beat
ridges and see from the helicopter you
can see the the tent rings you go to the
highest one it's going to be the oldest
you pull a radiocarbon sample out and
ideally it gives you your earliest date
so pre dorset are in the sort of
southern Canadian Arctic Arctic
Archipelago and northern most mainland
by around 3200 cal bc and then a few
hundred years later by about 2,400 cal
bc they spread throughout the rest of
the entire the entire Arctic these are
highly mobile small-scale people most of
their sites have only a single or two or
three ten rings there are some much
larger sites but most of them are very
small most of them have almost nothing
in them virtually no bone virtual
artifacts the implication being they're
really moving around a lot so you can
have entire regions with hundreds of
tenth rings and it could represent a
couple of families moving around over
several centuries well their descendants
be moving around as one or two families
as well large numbers of 10th rings and
large number of sites doesn't have to
represent big populations here there are
again a few exceptions a few very rich
sites in this period especially up up in
Greenland but for the most part these
are small-scale highly mobile people the
next big event in my simplified version
is the origin of Dorset in this case
represented by early and middle Dorset
this happens around 500 cal bc or a
little bit before it and here we see
really a pretty significant change it's
been brewing for a while there have been
some antecedent changes in the
archaeological record but but we do get
something now that really looks quite a
bit more sedentary with quite a bit more
elaborate in some senses material
culture and in some ways just looks more
comfortable this is a semi subterranean
house i excavated on victoria island in
the central Arctic and use hard kind of
hard to see but that is excavated about
60 centimeters into the cobble Beatrice
so it's truly semi sub training it's
just much more comfortable I think in
the winter than anything these pre
Dorset people lived in but just as
interesting for housing is that in the
Dorset period we get snow knives for the
first time these are the tools used by
recent Inuit for making snow houses
so-called egg lose so this also allowed
a whole new set of types of architecture
that again we're both comfortable but
also very useful and allowed a lot of
freedom for example you could now move
easily out onto the sea ice to do
hunting at wreathing holes which may
have been harder if not but not
impossible beforehand you also get a lot
of other kind of what is thought of a
sort of cold adaptive technologies sled
shoes those go along the bottom of sled
runners so they indicate they're
definitely have sleds probably didn't
have dogs these are probably hand drawn
sleds but they still would have allowed
easier transport than
not having them dorset ice creeper or
crampons these would have been strapped
on to the bottom of of the the chemical
or the boot to allow extra purchase when
you are hunting probably from the sea at
sea ice edge and you get a proliferation
of soapstone lamp so they're burning oil
for light and heat now to a greater
degree than they did before so again a
little more sedentary a little more
elaborate a little more ice adapted late
Dorset I coming in that this is kind of
iffy I kept playing with which dates i
was going to used here use here the
earliest late Dorset might be about 600
Cal ad we're now talking but the
expansion too much of the Arctic is
quite a bit later probably 800 or 900
Cal ad at that point you have really of
a very large part of the Eastern Arctic
occupied by late Dorset most of the
margins of Greenland were not occupied
by late Dorset but it they definitely
made it back into the High Arctic and
there's actually a pretty good pretty
high frequency of sites there so they
seem to have been doing quite well their
their subsistence and their life way is
pretty similar to the early and middle
Dorset that had come before them one of
the major sets of differences you get is
is art seemed to be more social and
ideological you get these enormous very
impressive Boulder outlined long houses
for example which seemed to be the site
of summer ritually charged aggregations
that probably happened every year or
every few years to to add cohesiveness
you get a lot more trade in the lake
Dorset period so both of these are
indications of interaction and just so I
could put up an ice sculpture Dorset has
a proliferation of art there's a lot of
representation of humans and animals
going on often with skeletal patterns
what may be indications of killing of
the animal it's very difficult of course
to figure out exactly what these mean
but they're suddenly an order of
magnitude more of them than there ever
had been before in the archaeological
record so something interesting is going
on so that's late Dorset
we now move to this completely different
tradition the ancestors of modern Inuit
and Inupiat the Thule into it this is
another one that has just over the last
10 years or so had a fairly radical
change in the consensus view of when it
happened until about 10 years ago most
of us thought that the migration the
tule migration from Alaska into the the
Canadian Arctic and Greenland happened
about a thousand ad we now think it's
sometime in the 13th century 1200 ad or
a little bit later not everybody agrees
but but a vast majority do and certainly
there's there's not a big rich tradition
of anything to Lee before that so it
really looks like it happens around 1200
ad to Lee are into it I mean everything
about their archaeological record is
recognizable in the ethnographic record
of Inuit in other words when you dig a
tuille site all you have to do is open
the classic ethnographies from the early
20th century late 19th century and every
well a slight exaggeration but almost
every tool you dig up you can just see a
picture of it and you know exactly what
it is which is handy to have these kind
of manuals to identify but the the Thule
Inuit technology is far more complex
there's just way more of it these people
are you know for every for every
activity they seem to have invented a
new a new implement they didn't seem to
reuse implements for multiple tasks and
a lot of it was heavy so these people
were much more sedentary much less
mobile they had very large semi
subterranean houses with often with deep
middens you know indicating living in
one spot year round or probably for at
least say nine months ten months of the
year this is there was the remains of a
of a Inuit tule intimate site the
classic whalebone site these are all
whale skulls and whale ribs and
mandibles used for the superstructure
interesting both to show how what big
elaborate houses they have but also just
to emphasize that wherever they could
get bowhead whales to Lee were the
master
hunters of bowhead whales and the dorset
who had come before them didn't hunt
large whales at all so this is a huge
difference between paleo intimate and
and Inuit just briefly i'm not going to
go through technology as a whole but
just to show you this is just a small
part of marine mammal hunting gear just
to show some of the elaboration that's a
bowhead whale hunting harpoon head has a
slot that you can't see up here which
would have had a very large slate blade
two other harpoon head types a lance
used for killing after the whale is
disabled and these rather unassuming
things are perhaps the most important
and what they are our float nozzles so
they were put on sealskin floats the
floats were of course inflated put on
the harpoon line and so unlike the
dorset who came before them they could
harpoon a whale throw the float in the
water the whale would tire itself out
and people were not really put in danger
whereas much whereas earlier people
didn't have floats and it's thought that
this one innovation which was developed
in the Bering Strait region before the
Thule migration was a huge factor in the
success of Julie and into it generally
and finally they had big dog sleds and
also these Umi acts are referred to you
can see how many people are in that it
doesn't look terribly safe i must admit
but you can just imagine how efficient
it would be to move a camp with a couple
of families and all their gear if you
are migrating across the Arctic and it
looks like some parts of the migration
with no exaggeration happened within 10
or 20 years all the way from Alaskan
home lines up to up to Greenland in all
places in between so it was extremely
rapid there may have been several waves
with accumulating accumulating
populations but it was a very rapid
process and so that's tule intimate and
then there's this kind of arbitrary
timeline of you know moment around 1500
kalady you could put a little later put
it a bit earlier when Tullio nuit sort
of developed in situ in two recent inuit
so of course when
intimate first encountered Europeans and
had their life ways recorded they were
quite different from thule in many ways
most intimate in the Eastern Arctic no
longer lived in these big semi
subterranean houses on land most of them
were now living in snow host villages on
the ice bowhead whaling was rare whereas
earlier with tule it had been common and
there's a lot of other small differences
as well so we do seem to see a change in
life way towards a little bit more
mobility especially in the winter and
changing again to these these sea ice
villages living in snow houses where
people are are hunting seals at their
breathing holes and the other thing we
see is a contraction of the range so
with tule we had at the maximum we had
most of the Arctic Archipelago occupied
at least briefly with the change to
recent Inuit around 1500 ad plus or
minus we did have gradual contraction
from north to south and in fact this map
is kind of generous there really wasn't
very much occupation in a lot of this
the northern part of this region so in
fact into it had moved quite far south
and here's sort of a classic case where
it's difficult to figure out the
causality of why they're moving south
because on the one hand if it's getting
colder as I'll get into it in a moment
that may well have been a driving force
but at the same time very shortly after
1500 AD of course we have Europeans
showing up with all of their desired
trade goods and it's at that point that
any what are really coming down the
Hudson Bay coast the Labrador coast and
so part of the motivation certainly was
to gain access to trade goods and other
opportunities as well so it's it's a
it's a complex thing so now I probably
almost at my time so this is this is the
last part of this this first half so
I'll probably just end here but I'm now
going to blithely try to say something
about what's the latest in terms of how
this dating might actually sync up with
with climate change now
I will start by saying that you know my
expertise such as it is it's primarily
archaeological I don't do a lot of paleo
climate paleo environmental stuff myself
although I try to read it what I've done
here is taken 20 two separate graphs
from the Kauffman at all article that
has been cited by a few people sort of
arbitrarily selected but both to be in
the east and to show two different proxy
measures for for temperature or for ice
conditions and then I've put the latest
information we have on dating up against
it to try to see see how it works out on
the left we have the borehole
temperature reconstructions from 22
sites one in central and one in southern
greenland this is through through a
complicated process bowhead whale
frequencies so bowhead whale frequencies
should be a proxy for open water you
should get higher frequencies these are
these are dead bowheads that have been
found on beach ridges where the beat
ridges can be dated and also the bullets
can be directly radiocarbon dated and so
basically the the more bowheads you get
all else being equal the warmer it
should be but of course for an
archaeologist that has the added
dimension of is if there's more bowheads
if people can hunt bo has that's also a
draw for for human migration so starting
at the bottom again i think i mentioned
that until very recently we thought that
these earliest Paley Wiener have made it
into the Arctic around 4,500 BP now we
think it's a little over five thousand
so in many ways to further back it gets
pushed the further it gets pushed into
Holocene thermal maximum territory even
though the cow phone article and others
are careful to point out just how
regionally variable it is how time to
Rend transgressive it is from from west
to east but for most of the
reconstructions there's a lot of
significant warmth going on until around
five thousand or a little later so it
does seem likely that when these first
paleo inuit made it into the made their
migration made their population
and that it was somewhat warmer and
because the locations of their sites
seemed to more or less sync up with
areas that should have had big caribou
herds and possibly musk ox populations
in other words terrestrial mammals there
could be some definite relationship
there between the initial move and
taking advantage of increased caribou
populations now this has to be tested
but that does seem like a decent
possibility the next of those big events
I'm just sort of inventing one big event
for those five those five cultural
tradition periods I gave you the next
one is the origin of doors now dorset of
all of these of all of these events or
processes Dorset is the origin divorce
is probably the most poorly known and
also in some ways probably the most
poorly david it's probably around here
maybe a little later traditionally
Dorset origins have been linked to
cooling temperatures and the thought has
been that all of those those phenomena
that I showed you the semi subterranean
houses the specialized technology for
ice edge hunting that kind of thing snow
house construction may have been linked
to an adaptation to colder temperatures
and in fact with these more recent
climate data arbitrarily selected though
they are it does appear to be syncing up
with general cooling general lowering of
or increases in sea ice and in fact you
know the the actual sort of diaspora of
Dorset throughout much of the Arctic
does happen a little later it actually
happens more like 200 well 2,200 BP so
that would place it near the bottom so
it again this is something that holds up
as a hypothesis to be tested that the
origin of Dorset could at least in part
be related to cooling temperatures the
next one is the late north of expansion
again that's this group that still looks
a lot like earlier Dorset but they
suddenly expand throughout a very large
area of the Arctic including the Western
art the Western Canadian Arctic and the
High Arctic and that one actually syncs
up really nicely
with the beginning of the Medieval Warm
Period it's actually pretty nicely
synced especial especially because this
is another one where I've been kind of
conservative with my dating but i think
the High Arctic probably wasn't occupied
until about a hundred years or 150 years
later than this bar would show a really
interesting one though is the tule
migration now the tule migration is
obvious at again at about 800 BP is
obviously happening in part during the
Medieval Warm Period what's interesting
about it is that back when we thought
the tule migration happened in a
thousand years ago it was often linked
to the beginning of the Medieval Warm
Period and the thought was almost that
the Medieval Warm Period expansion of
open water and bowheads was a trigger
for the thule migration now it seems to
me more likely that the bow heads had
already expanded and the conditions had
been there for a while and that it was
probably other factors that set the
thule migration off maybe social factors
back in Alaska but that once the
migration was under way it was greatly
aided by the fact that bullhead
populations were at an almost all time
high and were there for the pickens if
you knew how to hunt them and then
finally recent Inuit origins and again
this date of 500 years ago is totally
arbitrary because it depends on the
region as to when to leak sort of ends
and when when the Inuit pattern of
living on the sea ice begins but it's
clearly happening either at the start of
little ice age or it kind of a
transitional period between Medieval
Warm Period and Little Ice Age when
there's a lot of variability and
generally colder temperatures the date
of some of this especially when some of
the major bowhead whale hunting villages
is abandoned does appear to be earlier
than the arrival of any Europeans so
that does seem to implicate climate
change more than the draw of European so
I guess a current hypothesis would be
that cooling climates led to
families groups individuals starting to
try to make wise decisions about what to
do should they stay should they go
should they change and once they were on
the move or once they were making those
decisions later Europeans showed up and
much of their decisions were made in
order to take advantage of European
materials but that initially climate
probably did play a role in some of
those big changes between between to Lee
and and Inuit so again I'm just not
going to bother with this whole second
thing is I think I've kind of a half an
hour but yeah I was going to talk about
sites getting destroyed but if anyone
wants later I could I can talk about it
or show it or what have you so thank you
for listening and